For early access to future documentaries
and 30 plus exclusive adfree videos,
check out my Patreon link in the
description. Deepseek wasn't meant to
happen. The lines were well rehearsed.
The West had an ever growing lead in AI.
Language models were getting ever more
expensive as they got more intelligent.
And research was retreating behind a
veil of competitive secrecy. But on the
20th of January, 2025, those reading
those lines started to stutter. A model
that visibly seemed to think before it
spoke had been released. Deepseek R1. It
was unbelievably cheap, competitive with
the best the West had to offer and out
in the open, available to anyone to
download. Even OpenAI admit as much,
arguing in March that Deep Seek shows
quote that our lead is not wide and is
narrowing. OpenAI even want models like
Deepseek R1 banned because they say,
quote, "Deepse could be compelled by the
Chinese Communist Party to manipulate
its models to cause harm. And because
DeepSseek is simultaneously state
subsidized, state controlled, and freely
available, it will cost users their
privacy and security. Now, while
Google's Gemini 2.5 and the new chat GBT
image gen have wrestled back the
headlines at the beginning of April,
Deepseek is preparing to deliver yet
another shock to the system with
Deepseek R2 expected later in April or
May. But truth be told, many of you will
already know all of that. What you might
not know, though, are the aims and
beliefs expressed in desperate
interviews by the secretive founder
behind Deepseek, billionaire Leang
Wenfang, a man who now has to hide from
crowds of adoring fans in his own
hometown, according to a friend he
texted, and who has now fled his home
province with his family to escape
further attention. Nor will some of you
know about the first AI operation that
made Leang his money and then went arai
or the beauty of some of the technical
innovations behind the omega viral
Deepseek R1. Or just how the western
labs like OpenAI and Anthropic have
fired back with their own narratives in
the days and weeks since the release of
R1. There is frankly so much that so
many people don't know about the company
Deepseek and what it means. The truth is
that Deepseek is a whale caught in a net
of narratives, most of which contradict
each other. So, let's get as close as we
can to the truth behind the narratives
and what that truth says about where all
of this is going. Because if Leang
Wenfang is correct and artificial
general intelligence is quote 10, 5, or
even 2 years away, then this story is
about far far more than one man, one
lab, or even one nation. Here then is
what one of Leang's business partners
said of the man who was thought to be
40. He was this very nerdy guy with a
terrible hairstyle when they first met.
Talking about building a 10,000 chip
cluster to train his own AI models. We
didn't take him seriously. Of course,
there are many AI leaders with terrible
hairstyles. So, what sets Leang Wenfang
apart? He certainly wasn't always about
solving intelligence and making it free.
It's hard to become a billionaire that
way, as you might well guess. Now, to
seek out the origin story here, we must
switch to a firsthand account from the
man himself. Before that, though, a few
moments of background. Leang graduated
university into a world that was falling
apart. Some of you will be too young, of
course, to remember the panic of
September 2008 when the financial
pyramid built on the sands of the US
subprime housing market collapsed.
Either way, you might be able to
understand the drive Leang had to try to
understand the patterns within the
unfolding chaos and predict what would
come next. There were those who tried to
tempt him into different directions
while he operated out of a small flat in
Chungdu, Sichuan. Not me, though I was
there actually in Chungdu at the same
time learning Mandarin. No, no, no. It
was the founder of what would become
DJI, the world's preeminent drone maker,
who tried to headhunt Leang, but to no
avail. Leang had bigger ambitions. After
getting a mast's in information
engineering in 2010, Leang went on a
founding spree between 2013 and 2016,
culminating in the establishment of the
hedge fund Highflyier in February 2016.
Each entity he started included the core
goal of using machine learning to
uncover the patterns behind microscond
or even nanocond movements in the
financial markets. Patterns and
paradigms no humans could detect alone.
Artificial intelligence if you will
before it was called that. Of course, as
late as May 2023, Leang was still
describing his goal in financial terms.
Our broader research aims to understand
what kind of paradigms can fully
describe the entire financial market and
whether there are simpler ways to
express it. Anyway, it worked through
attracting $9.4 billion in assets under
management by the end of 2021 and
providing returns that in some cases
were 20 to 50 percentage points more
than stock market benchmarks. Leang
absolutely minted it. He was a
billionaire by his mid30s and on top of
the world. All of Highflyier's market
strategies used AI, and yes, they were
calling it that. And they even had a
supercomputer powered by 10,000 Nvidia
GPUs. He might not at this point be
scaling up language models like a tiny
American startup, OpenAI, had done the
year earlier in 2020 with GPT3. But had
his AI truly solved the chaos of the
financial markets, had he done it? No.
This is where the story starts to get
interesting. Leang's AI system, built
with a team of just over a 100
individuals, had a troublesome
personality quirk. It was frankly too
much of a risk-taker. It would double
down on bets when it felt it was right.
And that wasn't all. The hedge fund
itself, Highflyier, had become
hubristic. It was flying too close to
the sun. Success as a hedge fund, as you
might expect, attracts more investments.
If you don't limit your fund size, and
Leang didn't in time, then sometimes you
have too much money to deploy in a smart
way. Your trades get copied. Your edge
becomes less keen. So, after seeing a
sharp draw down, Highflyier expressed
its deep guilt in public and took
measures to further limit who could
invest with them. Yes, in case you're
curious, they did learn their lesson and
are still going as a hedge fund today
with some degree of success. Actually,
between 2018 and early 2024, Highflyer
has outperformed the Chinese equivalent
of the S&P index, albeit with some
stumbles since then. And yes, as we
know, Leang didn't give up on AI. He was
rich now and could afford an outfit
dedicated to decoding not just financial
systems, but the nature of general
intelligence itself. The effort would be
called Deep Seek, and it was first
formed as a research body in April 2023.
Any scars perhaps though for Leang from
his previous AI experience? Well, there
is one that might have carried over into
the paper Deepseek produced on their
first large language model or chatbot.
From his experience, Leang knew the AI
could be fickle and not always a
reliable partner. So, Deepseek added
this disclaimer for their first chatbot,
Deepseek V1, released in November 2023.
We profoundly recognize the importance
of safety for general artificial
intelligence. The premise for
establishing a truly helpful artificial
intelligence model is that it possesses
values consistent with those of humans
and exhibits friendliness towards
humanity. Before I continue any further
though, let's not pretend that many of
us in the West were paying much
attention to any of the developments
described so far. By then, of course,
OpenAI were well onto GPT4, which showed
sparks of AGI. GPT4 was released
publicly in March 2023, well before Deep
Seek was even officially founded in July
of that year. But at least the stage had
been set. A reclusive billionaire one
and a half decades deep into wielding
artificial intelligence to understand
the world. A man who had made his money
and was now, in his words, simply driven
to explore. Quote, "People," Yang said,
"m think there's some hidden business
logic behind Deepseek, but it's mainly
driven by
curiosity. Why did Deepseek R1 capture
the world's attention at the start of
2025? Why did it divide opinions and
convulse markets? Was it that the wider
world could see the thinking process of
the language model before it gave its
final answer? Was it that the Deep Seek
model was so cheap or that the model and
the methods behind it were so open and
accessible? Or was it that such a
performant model had come from China
which was supposed to be a year behind
the Western Frontier? We will
investigate each of these possibilities.
But there was one thing that was certain
of the Deep Seek of summer 2023. It was
indeed deeply behind Western AI Labs. By
then, don't forget, not only was GBC4
out and about, but so was the first
version of Claude from Anthropic and
Bard from Google and even Llama 2 from
Meta. Deepseek, by the way, paid
particular attention to Llama 2. That
model might not have been quite as smart
on key benchmarks as Gypsy 4, but it was
so-called open weights, which means
almost anyone could download, tweak, and
deploy the model as they saw fit. A
model is of course nothing without its
weights or its billions of tweakable
numerical values used to calculate
outputs. To be clear, open weights isn't
quite the same as open source. As to be
open source, we would need to see the
data that went into training the model,
the source, so to speak, which we did
not and still do not know. Despite some
models like Llama 2 being open weights,
at least key leaders within western AI
labs were saying that the frontier would
increasingly belong to those who kept
secret the methodology behind their
language model training as open AI did.
Here's Ilia Sutsker at the time the
chief scientist of OpenAI. He was saying
there will always be a gap between the
open models and the private models and
this gap may even be increasing. Sam
Orman, CEO and co-founder of OpenAI went
further. It wasn't just that research
secrets were becoming a moat. So too was
money. In June of 2023 in India, Sam
Orman replied to a question about
whether a team with just $10 million
could compete with OpenAI. His response
for me became a wider comment on whether
it was possible for any startup to enter
the race and build a truly intelligent
language model. Look, the way this works
is we're going to tell you it's totally
hopeless to compete with us on training
foundation models. you shouldn't try and
it's your job to like try anyway and I
believe both of those
things and I think it I think it is
pretty hopeless but not just this a
month earlier in May he had put it even
more bluntly there will be the
hyperscalers best closed source models
and there will be the progress that the
open source community makes and it'll be
you know a few years behind or whatever
a couple years behind maybe as we
learned a few weeks before these
comments Leang had launched launched
what would become Deep Seek. In short,
remember this context when you wonder at
the order reaction to Deepseek R1 in
January 2025. It wasn't supposed to be
like this. Intelligence was supposed to
come from the scale of the base model
measured not just in how many tens of
thousands of Nvidia GPUs were used to
compute the parameters of that model,
but on how much data it was trained on.
It just made sense that no one could
compete without the backing of
multi-trillion dollar hyperscalers like
Microsoft or Google. Leangfang was rich,
but not that rich. Leang must have known
that these Western Lab leaders thought
what he was about to attempt was
impossible, but he tried anyway. Nor
would he be distracted by the law of
quick monetization through routes like
$20 subscriptions. Leang said in May of
2023, "Our goal is clear to focus on
research and exploration rather than
vertical domains and applications." So,
Deepseek focused its recruitment efforts
on those who were young, curious, and
crucially Chinese. By the way, not even
Chinese returnees from the West were
favored. Leang added, "Deepse
prioritizes capability over credentials.
Core technical roles are primarily
filled by recent grads or those one to
two years out. These intellectual foot
soldiers would not be way laid by the
need to release on a schedule to compete
with open AAI. That was what had led
Google to release a botched bard and
Microsoft a comically weward Bing. Our
evaluation standards are quite different
from those of most companies. We don't
have KPIs, key performance indicators,
or so-called quotas. In our experience,
innovation requires as little
intervention and management as possible,
giving everyone the space to explore and
the freedom to make mistakes. All that
said, Deepseek's first pair of AI models
released in November 2023 were not
exactly stunning in their originality.
As I hinted at earlier, their V1 large
language model drew heavily upon the
innovations of Meta's Llama 2 LLM. And
neither of their November releases, Deep
See Koda or V1, made waves in the
Western media as attention at that time,
you may remember, focused on Sam Alman
being temporarily fired from OpenAI for
lack of cander. But there were just a
few signs that Deepseek were indeed
focused on long-termism, as each of
their papers explicitly claim. For
example, DeepSeek excluded
multiplechoice questions from their
bespoke training data set so that their
models would not overperform on formal
tests but underwhelm in practice. And
that's a lesson not learned by all AI
labs at the time or even now. Deepseek
wrote, quote, overfitting to benchmarks
would not contribute to achieving true
intelligence in the model. By the
beginning of 2024, the Deepseek team was
cooking with gas. In January, they
pioneered a novel approach to getting
more intelligence from their models for
less. Bear in mind that models like
Llama 2 used their entire set of
weights, often tens or hundreds of
billions strong, to compute a response
to a user prompt. That contrasted with
the mixture of experts approach, which
was not at all original to Deepseek. The
mixture of experts approach involves
using a specialized subset of those
weights depending on the user input,
thereby tapping into one or more of the
set or mix of experts within the model,
if you will. But think about it, because
only a subset of the model weights would
respond to each request, every expert
within the model had to have a degree of
common capability. A tiny bit like
forcing Messi to spend hours a week
practicing goalkeeping. And yes, I am
talking about soccer. If you are
American, could DeepSeek utilize the
mixture of experts approach which is
highly efficient without that key
downside? You probably guessed the
answer from my tone, but yes, in their
towards ultimate expert specialization
paper, here's the innovation. Certain
expert subnet networks within the
language model would always be activated
in any response. Those guys could be the
generalists. This meant that the
remaining experts like Messi could truly
focus on what they are good at. And yes,
just in case you're thinking ahead, this
is also one of the many secrets behind
the base model that powers Deep Seek R1,
the global phenomenon. Deepseek were
just getting warmed up though. In April
of 2024, they released Deepseek Math, a
tiny model that matched the performance
in mathematics at least of GPT4, a
Goliath of a model in comparison. What's
the deal with Deepseek Math then? Well,
one of the secrets behind the model
success was the unassumingly named group
relative policy optimization. A
mouthful, but it's a training method
later incorporated, you guessed it, by
the celebrated Deep Seek R1. Here then
is the TLDDR on that beast of a training
innovation. All language models need to
do more than just predict the next word,
which is what they learn in
pre-training. They need post-training to
move from predicting the most probable
word to the most helpful sets of words
as judged by humans and ultimately for
mathematical reasoning or coding steps,
the most correct word. Think of it like
this. You can't be smarter than Twitter
if all you do is train to predict the
next tweet. This takes careful
reinforcement of the weights of the
model that produce these desired
outputs. Yes, this was by mid2024
wellknown. But what was the magic behind
GRPO? Deepseek's new flavor of
reinforcement learning. Well, Deepseek
needed efficiency to fight the AI
giants. Common reinforcement learning
approaches at the time used chunky,
clunky critic models to assess answers
as they were being generated to predict
which ones were headed for success.
Deepseek dropped this memoryheavy critic
and instead generated a group of answers
in parallel checked the yes no accuracy
of the final outputs and then using the
relative score of each answer above or
below the average accuracy of the group
of answers reinforced the successful
weights in the model and downweighted
others. Group of answers relative score
reinforcing the most successful weights.
Group relative policy optimization.
Stepping back then, each of these
innovations was desperately essential to
keep Deepseek within reach of the
resource behemoths behind CactBT,
Claude, and Gemini. By May of 2024,
Lyang's lab shipped Deepseek V2 with yet
another efficiency miracle, multi-head
latent attention. Now, don't worry,
there's no deep dive coming on this one,
but forgive me just a few words on how
Deep Seek yet again reduced how big a
model had to be to reach a similar level
of performance. Think of multi head
latent attention as allowing multiple
parts of the model to share common
weights that are hidden or latent when
they quote pay attention. If you're
wondering, this attention mechanism is
the process by which language models
deduce which parts of the preceding text
are most relevant for predicting the
next word. Sharing those latent or
hidden weights when paying attention
meant that this model needed fewer of
the weights overall. Shared weights,
smaller model, greater efficiency.
Deepseek V2. Okay, we get it. The point
has probably now been made. The Deepseek
R1 was not a CIO Xnihilo created from
thin air. It was built on the back of
painstaking innovations amassed over
almost 2 years and made open to the
world, funded, of course, by a reclusive
billionaire. But wait, why did Leang
need so much efficiency? Because yes,
Deepseek had indeed secured 10,000
Nvidia A100 GPUs for high-f flyier stock
trading in 2021, but the US government
did not want to let Chinese companies
get their hands on more powerful chips.
One after another, restrictions were
introduced by the Biden administration
to stop China getting the compute that
it wanted. Nvidia tried to wrigle its
way past these restrictions by inventing
new chips that scraped under these
limits. But each time a new restriction
followed. As Leang himself said in the
summer of 2024, "Money has never been
the problem for us. Bans on shipments of
advanced chips are the problem." That's
the context. The march to more powerful
AI was now being framed as a race, even
a quote war that perhaps inevitably
kicked off a spree of smuggling worthy
of a spy movie with Singapore and
Malaysia as focal points for Chinese
companies getting chips past the new
blockade. Think of this. Some of the
GPUs used in China to calculate R1's say
recipe for Ratatouille were apparently
smuggled there in suitcases with I would
guess little space left for spare socks.
And this brings us to the end of 2024
with the stage almost set. Leang Wenfang
toiling his Haou office repeatedly
reading papers, writing code, and
participating in group discussions just
like every other researcher at deepseek
well into the night. That company now in
the line of sight of AI industry
insiders, but virtually unknown to the
public outside of China. A whale rising,
but still just beneath the surface as a
new year dawned.
[Applause]
[Music]
Leang Wenfang was tired of the West
inventing things and China swooping in
to imitate and monetize those
innovations. What's more surprising
though is that he publicly said as much.
China should gradually become a
contributor instead of freeriding. He
said in his last known media interview,
he went on to directly cite the scaling
law, an empirical finding first made in
Silicon Valley that language models get
predictably better the more parameters
they had and the more high-quality data
they train on. In the past 30 plus years
of the IT wave, Leang said of China, "We
basically didn't participate in real
technological innovation. We're used to
Moore's law falling out of the sky,
lying at home waiting 18 months for
better hardware and software to emerge.
That is how the scaling law is being
treated. No, Leang wanted Deepseek to be
a pioneer that gave away its research
which others could then learn from and
adapt. In the dying days of 2024,
Deepseek produced Deepseek V3. It was
the bringing together and scaling up of
all the innovations you have already
heard about as well as others. Why not
throw in some mixed precision training
where in your obsession with efficiency
has to reach such crack addict levels
that you handw write code to optimize
instructions to the Nvidia GPU itself
rather than relying on the popular CUDA
libraries that Nvidia provides for you.
With V3, Deepseek's Culpix were almost
worn blunt from finding nuggets of
efficiency. And though the hour was
late, Western labs were at last
scrambling teams to study Deepseek's
breakthroughs. Dario Ammedday, CEO of
Anthropic, said that quote, "Deepseek's
V3 was actually the real innovation."
And what should, he said, have made
people take notice a month ago. We
certainly did. Deepseek knew to keep
digging, though, because OpenAI had
shown that there was gold just ahead. In
September of 2024, OpenAI had showcased
a new type of reinforcement learning
that utilized the chains of thought a
model produces before it submits a final
answer. As we've seen, a model whose
goal is to predict what a human on the
web might say next will always be
limited in capability. The O series from
OpenAI showed that if instead you first
induce the model to reason out loud,
then apply brutal optimization pressure
in favor of those outputs that match
verifiably correct answers in domains
like mathematics and coding, you thereby
optimize for the most technically
accurate continuation and unveil a whole
new terrain of reasoning progress to be
explored. Because of Leang Wenfang,
Deepseek was there ready and waiting,
pick in hand, adding this think out loud
reasoning innovation on top of their V3
base model produced Deep Seek R1 Zero.
Yes, Zero. But the thoughts of that
model could be a little wayward in
language and style. So with some further
tweaks and fine-tuning, Deepseek could
unveil Deep Seek R1, the AI that has
billions of people talking. In many
technical benchmarks, R1 narrowly
surpassed the performance of the
original 01 model from OpenAI in
September, and in others, it was not far
behind. By being open with their
research, Deep Seek showed the world how
language models, under that unrelenting
optimization pressure to produce correct
answers, could sometimes backtrack and
even correct themselves. It was an aha
moment for the models and for the world
realizing just how close a secretive
Chinese lab was to household names like
ChachiBT. Don't get me wrong, there were
other innovations in the Deep Seek R1
paper, including how their biggest and
smartest models could effectively
distill much of their abilities into
smaller models, saving those models much
of the work to get up to scratch. The
explain it like I'm 10 of that
innovation is that models that can fit
onto phones and home computers or served
at incredibly low cost from anywhere are
now set in 2025 to be smarter than the
smartest giant models of 2024. But why
the virality of Deepseek R1? Was it the
fact that you could see those thoughts
in the Deepseek chat that made the model
so compelling? Or the fact that it was
so cheap that caused Nvidia stocks to
plunge by almost half a trillion
dollars? Leang had said himself, by the
way, that he quote didn't expect pricing
to be so sensitive to everyone. Okay.
Was it Deepseek's openness that was so
shocking? 100 narratives have bloomed in
the days and weeks after the release of
Deepseek R1, but not all of them are as
they seem. First, let's address those
chains of thought. In hindsight, it
might seem obvious that gaining
privileged access to a model's thoughts
was always going to stand out in a
crowded market. Open AAI only gave
sanitized summaries of its 01 models
thoughts after all. But wait, within
hours of the R1 release, Google had
given us Gemini 2.0 flash thinking, a
model that showed its thoughts. That
model's impact on the scene can best be
described as a cute ripple next to R1
Tsunami. So, it must have been the
price, right? By some metrics, R1's 95%
cheaper than competitively capable
models from OpenAI. But wait, Gemini 2
Flash is even cheaper. And again, just a
polite round of applause. Okay, maybe
it's the fact that the model cost just
$6 million to train, which is a measly
sum in the circumstances. Well, on that,
let's take a moment to at least hear out
the argument from the leaders of the
Western Labs on price, even if you have
reason to doubt their motivation.
Anthropic CEO Dario Ammedday first
responded by describing how costs had
already been consistently dropping 4x
per year for the same amount of model
capability. He even wrote a full article
to in part clarify that quote even if
you take Deep Seek's training cost at
face value, they are on trend at best
and probably not even that. He did admit
that what was different in his words was
that the company that was first to
demonstrate the expected cost reductions
was Chinese. Deepseek's GPU investments
alone account for more than $500
million. Even after considering export
controls, their total server capital
expenditure is around 1.6 billion. Even
a $6 million training run doesn't just
appear from nowhere. Indeed, things are
getting so costly for Deep Seek that
even Leang's vast pockets are reaching
their limits. According to reports from
February of 2025, Leang is considering
raising outside money for the first
time, potentially from Alibaba Group and
Chinese state affiliated funds. Why
would so much money be needed? Well,
it's not just to serve the tens of
millions of daily active users the Deep
Seek now has. It's to scale model
intelligence further all the way to AGI
an artificial intelligence as general in
applicability as our own. According to
Altman and Amade, tacking on that think
out loud reasoning optimization to a
great base model can yield outsized
dividends at first which have allowed
Deepseek to catch up. But to ride that
upward curve into the vicinity of AGI,
you'll need tens of billions of dollars
worth of compute, they argue. Amade
wrote, "We're therefore at an
interesting crossover point where it is
temporarily the case that several
companies can produce good reasoning
models. This will rapidly cease to be
true as everyone moves further up the
scaling curve on these models." Making
AI, he said, that is smarter than almost
all humans at almost all things, will
require millions of chips, tens of
billions of dollars at least, and is
most likely to happen in
2026, 2027. Even forgetting Deep Seek
for a moment, that is quite the quote.
If he's right though, and it's a big if,
those Chinese corporate jet setters are
going to have to smuggle god knows how
many GPUs under their pack pajamas. But
Amade has a word on that. $1 billion of
economic activity can be hidden, but
it's hard to hide a hundred billion or
even 10 billion. A million chips may
also be physically difficult to smuggle.
Without enough chips, according to this
argument, Deepseek R2 and R3 can't help
but fall behind. We simply do not know
if the Deep Seek engineers can keep
building at the pace of those working
with billiondollar bricks. While we're
on China, there is another narrative
that I want to debunk. You may have been
told that Deep Seek is a one-off and
that China lacks the environment to
properly foster innovation in AI. Well,
even if you cast aside the text to image
and text to video wonders produced by
tools like Cling AI, you are still left
with a landscape full of new models like
Dobau 1.5 Pro from Bite Dance, makers of
Tik Tok, released within hours actually
of R1. Oh, and a week before that, we
got Spark Deep Reasoning X1 from iFly
Techch and Huawei, which beats Western
models at Chinese technical exams and is
used by almost 100 million people
already. And on January the 20th, the
literal same day that R1 was released,
the Chinese research firm Moonshot AI
launched the multimodal model Kimmy
K1.5, achieving 96.2% on a popular math
benchmark. Yes, that's a better score
than OpenAI's 01. So, anyone saying that
R1 is the last we're going to hear from
China for quite a while might well be
getting nervous, especially with R2
apparently imminent. Now, I can't cover
present and future Chinese language
models without mentioning another
narrative that might need busting. That
the open nature of the Deep Seek R1
paper is reflected in the openness of
the model itself. Because as many of you
will know, the model is not free to
return outputs on sensitive Chinese
topics. Not that it doesn't know
anything about them, though. I asked a
simple question. Tell me about the
Weaguers and got this intriguing set of
thoughts. This has to lead to an
illuminating and deeply reflective final
answer. We're sure, right? M not so
much. Yes, Deepseek's R1 model was
released under MIT license. So, of
course, others have been quick to adapt
the model to well, speak its truth.
Regardless though, I am sure that this
is a topic that DeepS and Leang Wenfang,
if they're watching, are exceptionally
keen for me to move on from. So, let's
turn to how OpenAI tried briefly to
establish their own counternarrative,
which was that Deep Seek may have
illicitly accessed the chains of thought
of OpenAI's 01 model and trained on
them. Think of that as effectively
stealing the intelligence that had been
so carefully cultivated by OpenAI. A
spokesperson for OpenAI said, "We know
that groups in China are actively
working to use methods, including what's
known as distillation, to try to
replicate advanced US AI models. We are
aware of and reviewing indications that
DeepS may have inappropriately distilled
our models. We take aggressive,
proactive countermeasures to protect our
technology and will continue working
closely with the US government to
protect the most capable models being
built here." Side note, speaking of
working with the government, certain US
lawmakers are proposing that US users be
jailed if they use Deepseek R1. Back to
the counternarrative that died in the
public imagination almost as soon as it
was tried for one obvious reason. OpenAI
themselves are being sued by everyone,
including my second cousin's aranged
grandmother, for knowingly training on
copyrighted works without compensation.
So, one suspects few will have any
sympathy for those companies if others
like DeepSeek distill anything from
Chacht, even if they needed to, which
they probably didn't, by the way.
Regardless, reasoning is being automated
at a breakneck pace. As hard to believe
as the Deep Seek Rise is, for me, it's
actually only a pointer to a bigger
story. We are actually entering an era
of automated artificial intelligence.
And no, the models will not always best
be described as tools akin to a
calculator. If an AI in three years time
can do 95% of my job or yours, at what
point am I just a tool responsible only
for clicking submit? Granted, we are
very much not there yet. Of course, it
is Deep Seek our one after all. And yes,
humans are still just about in the
driving seat. meaning I guess the only
thing absolutely guaranteed is
drama. That then was the Deep Seek story
as best we know it. What is next though
for the Tacetern Leang Wenfang and his
team of wizards? The R1 paper hints that
they are deep in the mind still working
on infinite context and a replacement
for the legendary transformer
architecture behind every famous
language model. But just take infinite
context where we can imagine a model
provided everything you have ever heard
or seen or said and referencing any of
it when it gives you its next answer.
Will Deepseek do it? Will they reach AGI
first? Would they actually open source
it? If so, will the world grasp even a
fraction of what is happening before
that day or only after? Well, it
probably won't be long before we find
out.
[Music]